this is why you won't be seeing any
lumen sponsorships from me hey everyone
i'm abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video i will be answering the
age-old question can you
hack your metabolism with a simple
device that's right we're talking about
lumen but first let me tell you what my
sponsor element so you guys know i
review a lot of fitness creators and
athletes here at abby's kitchen and one
of the biggest nutrition mistakes that
my sports rd colleagues and i see is not
properly rehydrating when extra
hydration is indicated for a lot of
people plain water is just fine but for
folks doing longer higher intensity
workouts exercising in the heat or who
are just what we like to call salty
sweaters there's definitely a role for a
well-balanced electrolyte replacement so
when i pulled my sports rd colleagues a
lot of them told me that element was
their personal go-to product because it
has a science-backed electrolyte ratio
of a thousand milligrams of sodium 200
milligrams potassium and 60 milligrams
of magnesium it also has no added sugar
coloring gluten artificial sweeteners or
other ingredients for folks who are
extra sensitive and it's been the go-to
electrolyte replacement for us olympians
special forces and other professional
athletes i myself am not doing any
strenuous activity right now but i did
use this product when i was nursing and
pumping because i felt i was having a
hard time keeping up with the hydration
demand and the dietitian that i work
with now actually recommended it to me
as part of my supplement regimen to help
support my anxiety and sleep related
struggles all the flavors are super
delicious but i am low-key obsessed with
the mango chili so if you want to give
element a try you can get a whole sample
pack of eight different flavors for the
price of shipping that's just five
dollars for us orders so check out the
link in the description to get yours and
folks you can pause the screen or look
at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating so as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that subscribe button and don't forget
to follow me over on tick tock and
instagram abby's kitchen also a huge
thank you to my colleague eric
williamson who gave me tons and tons of
amazing important insight into this
topic so i am going to be leaving his
information down below all right let's
kick things off here first things first
what exactly is lumen here we go again
well a lot of you showed up in my dms to
ask about this new technology after
blogilati's partnered with them on her
instagram page in march so for my
birthday sam bought me this thing
because he knows i love devices that
tell me more about my body it's called a
lumen and he told me it might help me
improve my metabolism so every morning i
blow into it and it tells me if i'm
burning fat or carbs it's measuring my
metabolic flexibility which is my body's
ability to switch between burning fat or
carbs for feel it'll score you between
one to five and based on what score you
get lumen will recommend some
macronutrients to help you burn more fat
so right now i'm going super high
protein i'm also trying to sleep eight
hours a day because if i do not my body
will be in stress mode and basically
it'll be harder for me to burn fat now
all of this so that i can build more
muscle next month i'll be focused on fat
burn because it'll be time to put on
that sparkly bikini and prepare for that
faux bikini competition stage walk now
you've probably seen other endorsements
from people like steve farina lizabeth
lopez health coach kate dr caroline leaf
heidi powell and so many more and i also
want to share that i have also been
approached for a partnership multiple
times and have respectfully declined
everyone
how about new including one time when
they cryptically let us on about a new
wellness technology only to tell us by
like the 10th email that surprise it's
actually lubin not cool pr peeps not
cool but bottom line my team and i have
done a lot of research on this tool in
short lumen is a handheld
breathalyzer-like device that claims to
hack your metabolism by making it more
efficient improving metabolic
flexibility enhancing fat burning and
promoting weight loss what's in your
life the technology works by analyzing
your breath to determine if your body is
burning fat or it's burning carbs and
based on this information it will then
recommend a meal plan to keep you in the
fat burning zone for weight loss but can
lumen really walk the talk or talk the
walk or whatever that phrase is and more
importantly does this even help you lose
weight well first of all let's talk
about the legitimacy or lack thereof
with this technology so basically when
you breathe into the lumen device it
claims to calculate what we call the
respiratory exchange ratio aka rer which
looks at your co2 to oxygen levels rer
is an indicator of our source of fuel
which then gives lumen data about our
metabolic flexibility level i'm going to
speak more to that in just a moment but
basically if your result reads a high
co2 to oxygen ratio you're predominantly
burning carbs but if you have a low co2
reading it means that your body is using
fat now when looking at the data on the
device eric agreed that this device had
pretty good within participant
reliability but a weak relationship with
measured rer so in other words it may be
able to tell you how your metabolic
flexibility is changing over time but
not if you are more flexible than let's
say your friend
yes which is valuable but not everything
it's also important to point out that
most of the validation studies that
lumens cites are conducted by lumen
themselves which have not been peer
reviewed and are subject to bias there
was one external study conducted by san
francisco state university which
concluded that lumen is comparable to
the gold standard for measuring rer and
might be an effective way to monitor
changes in metabolic responses however
it's important to note that two of the
study's authors also work for metaflo
which is the company that founded lumen
which some may consider a source of
external bias obviously this doesn't
necessarily mean that lumen doesn't
accurately measure metabolism i actually
think that it probably does but the
question remains whether or not it will
help you hack said metabolism as it
claims so let's talk about the most
important piece of this puzzle metabolic
flexibility so i briefly discussed
metabolic flexibility in my video on
intuitive fasting but in short it refers
to your body's ability to switch between
carbs and fat for fuel definition wise
it's the change in fuel oxidation to
fuel availability which is measured as
the change in rer but according to the
folks at lumen the more flexible your
metabolism the more efficiently you can
lose weight and their advice allegedly
helps give you that edge well lumen
aside there are a few evidence-based
ways to improve our metabolic
flexibility largely related to either
mitochondrial biogenesis or insulin
sensitivity so those are exercise and
fitness leanness and body composition
and a negative energy balance the
mitochondria piece is pretty complicated
but it is important in the context of
athletes and sports nutrition but for
more lay people insulin sensitivity is
directly related to our metabolic
flexibility because the more sensitive
our cells are to insulin the more
effectively they are able to use up
carbs for energy then once those carbs
are all used up the body is then able to
tap into fat stores for energy but
insulin resistance makes it more
difficult for your cells to respond to
insulin and use up carbs for energy and
therefore it can't so easily switch to
burning fat this is such a complicated
topic but the relationship between
insulin resistance and metabolic
inflexibility may explain why impaired
metabolic flexibility is linked to
things like obesity diabetes and
metabolic syndrome but aside from
physical fitness body composition and
energy balance can we hack our
metabolism into being more flexible just
by following a specific diet well this
is essentially what lumen suggests when
you breathe into the device you get a
score from one to five which determines
if you're burning predominantly carbs
fat or both lumen will then recommend a
daily meal plan that's either low medium
or high carb lumen doesn't explicitly
recommend restrictive diets and i would
say that the meal plans are pretty
customizable and user friendly which we
love good for us the focus here seems to
be primarily on adjusting the relative
macronutrient ranges depending on where
you score and while i haven't used the
device personally myself i have read a
lot of people's reviews and i do have
some concerns with the approach for one
lumen recommends fasting overnight which
does make sense in this case because we
know that when we starve the body of
fuel overnight we dry up our glycogen
stores which then allows us to start to
burn into our fat stores so in the
morning we will generally register as
burning fat which is obviously what most
lay people are going to want to see most
of the time and this is a totally normal
healthy metabolic pattern assuming that
you're not in a caloric surplus i've
also read that most people find that
they're given instructions to eat low
carb for like several days in a row
before finally getting a moderate or
high carb meal and i can see why they do
this too it's probably very encouraging
to see that you are often burning fat
which is what would happen if you were
consistently eating low carb this is
also what happens all the time if you're
doing straight up keto but if you were
doing straight up keto your body would
adapt to fat oxidation and may actually
acutely make you more metabolically
inflexible and unable to efficiently use
carbs when you cheat and have a side of
fries you actually want to see a high
rer when you eat carbs because it's the
change in rer not a chronically low rer
that denotes a strong metabolic
flexibility so i appreciate that lumen
tries to address the shortcomings of
like a continuous low carb or keto diet
by giving you an occasional higher carb
day to keep your metabolism kind of like
nimble but i also worry that most people
will not appreciate the nuance of a
score system like this and the actual
long-term goal the actual goal should
not to always see a low lumen number
like a one or a two which indicates that
you're burning fat if that's what you
want just do keto and like never ever
eat a piece of bread again but that
sucks
the gold lumen should be to see
variation in those numbers depending on
what you ate you want to burn carbs when
you eat carbs and you want to burn fat
when you eat fat i'm going to speak more
to the dangerous psychological
assumptions that this may promote in a
moment but i do think it may be missing
the forest from the trees and that
forest is the goal of long-term
metabolic flexibility it may be exciting
to see that you're burning fat but
unless your diet choices are directly
changing your body fat insulin
sensitivity fitness level or body
composition its effects on long-term
metabolism hacking will likely
underwhelm but let's just say you were
able to improve your metabolic
flexibility with a device like lumen
would that necessarily help you lose
weight well probably not all on its own
but as eric pointed out maybe indirectly
so like i said the primary factors
driving metabolic flexibility are
exercise and leanness so metabolic
flexibility is kind of more like the
outcome rather than the solution per se
for losing weight it may help but it's
not the end-all be-all so a program like
lumen may support weight loss if someone
sees that they're in the fat burning
zone after like a workout on the app or
like after a really low carb meal and
they feel motivated to continue in this
calorie deficit way of life but at the
end of the day it's you
not the device that has to do the work
only you can prevent wildfire so whether
you're burning carbs or fat for fuel
eating a low medium or a high carb diet
you've still got to put yourself in a
calorie deficit or exercise to lose that
weight you're not going to burn fat if
you're in a calorie surplus even if the
app says that you are and carbohydrate
metabolism may be one small piece of the
puzzle but it's likely overshadowed by
other factors like total calories
consumed exercise sleep stress and
genetics you also have to consider the
potential downsides to a gadget like
this so lumen makes it seem like you can
magically fix your metabolism just by
blowing into a device something fishy
going on here but what seems to get
downplayed in a lot of the influencer
ads is the fact that you have to
literally plan your whole day of eating
in the morning around whatever the
stupid app says you can't meal prep you
can't make plans and if you get told
it's a low-carb day you have to cancel
your pasta date night your work drinks
or your birthday cake with friends
i also think it risks us immediately
assigning a lot of guilt and fear around
certain foods based on a random reading
for example if you had pizza for dinner
and the next morning saw that you're
still burning all those carbs you might
feel really bad that you've been kicked
out of the fat burning mode and start to
see carbs in a really negative light
i've read a lot of reviews of people
waking up every morning and feeling
completely defeated and in an automatic
bad mood when they score a high four or
five after a night with friends and like
i said this is actually totally normal
so waiting to eat the next day until you
register your burning fat again feels
incredibly disorderly it's just as
obsessive and intrusive as weighing
yourself multiple times a day for
external data so it definitely can be a
very slippery slope at the end of the
day if weight loss is the goal we know
how important diet tolerance and
adherence is hence why the research
tells us that weight loss outcomes on
low carb and low fat diets are pretty
much the same it comes down to what
works for you based on what foods you
enjoy if you really like oatmeal for
breakfast you're going to be in a
sourpuss mood if you have to eat eggs
and avocado so please
somebody tell me how is any minute and
transient improvements in metabolic
flexibility going to be worth letting a
tiny expensive handheld device run your
social life and your relationship with
food hard pass from me so in conclusion
well i do think that lumen might provide
some interesting data on your metabolism
and the factors that may impact it like
diet sleep and exercise and i'm so
excited to see the technology evolve any
weight loss outcomes are really going to
depend on your ability to stick to a
diet that creates a caloric deficit your
body is just too damn smart to have it
be hacked by a simple app you are still
responsible for said hack and on that
note that is all that i have for you
guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on what you'd like to see
me review next subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]